I'm Bob decima I'm the director of the
McGovern Institute for brain research
here at MIT just very briefly the
McGovern Institute was founded in the
year 2000 by Pat and Laurie McGovern
with a dual mission to understand the
mind and brain and then to apply that
knowledge to helping people with many
different forms of brain disorders
including Parkinson's disease as part of
our part of our outreach we periodically
host events like this for our friends
and supporters and members of the public
who are coming in for the first time and
it is really a thrill for us to be able
to talk to you about some of the things
that we're doing here and we'd love to
get your feedback and we'd love to have
you stay involved with us and sign up
for the newsletter and so on we have a
really exciting I think a schedule plan
for you and I want to thank you for
being here unfortunately we have a
government agency visiting us at exactly
the same moment and I have to make a
pitch for money so I hope you will
excuse me because I need to run out for
a bit but I will be back and I'm going
to turn over as master of ceremonies to
Charles Jennings who's the director of
the McGovern Institute neuro technology
program and our head of communications
at the montgomery institute charles
himself has a long and distinguished
career in science he was a former editor
at nature of the premier science
magazine founded Nature Neuroscience
magazine worked at the Harvard Stem Cell
Institute in the Allen Institute and we
have so fortunate to have him here
working with us and Charles will
introduce our upcoming speakers and
handle things while I gobble
okay thank you Bob and welcome everybody
it's a great pleasure to see so many of
you here old friends new new friends and
we're really excited that you that that
you're able to join us and we're very
grateful to the American Parkinson
disease Association for the opportunity
to partner with them in this event
that's Bob mentioned briefly this is one
in a series of outreach events that we
have been holding with different disease
advocacy organizations ready to try to
sort of spread the word if you like
about the work that we're doing and the
ties that we are building to the
clinical research and clinical community
and colleagues and so tonight's tonight
or this afternoon's theme is Parkinson's
disease and we have a really exciting
lineup of speakers for you and we just
briefly to to tell you the format we
will have about probably not quite an
hour of presentations from our three
speakers and we will then open the
Proceedings up to a question and answer
session with the floor and we hope that
you will all pitch in and fire any
question that you want at any of us and
we really enjoy these these two and
froze and we have people too and we will
then have a reception outside starting
at 5:30 and for anyone who is interested
we're also providing a tour of our
Imaging Center so you can come and see
some of some of our newest toys the
equipment that we use for scanning the
human brain and some of the most
advanced brain imaging equipment in the
world is is right within this building
just a couple of floors below us and
we'd be delighted to you take a look at
it and so with that I will move to the
to the speakers so we have three
speakers tonight I will introduce them
in in in turn but the the we start with
Roberto Sydney who I think many of you
know as another chair of our friends of
the McGovern Institute refer to will
give a an overview from a lay
perspective what it's like to be a
family member a family member and
affected by brain disease we will then
move on to an Graybiel who is a
professor here at the McGovern Institute
who if you were a sense of the research
that we are doing here on Parkinson's
disease and on the neurobiology related
to Parkinson's and then we will the
final speaker will be Maurice and
Hilaire who is the director of the
Parkinson's disease movement disorder
Center and I'll come back and introduce
her in more detail later on but she will
give a clinical perspective on where the
field is at in terms of the development
of new treatments but I will start with
Roberta
so Roberta as I said is is the chair of
the Friends of the McGovern Institute
she's a tremendous and dynamic supporter
of our work and she will tell you
herself about how she became interested
but I wanted to at a particular welcome
to Roberta's parents and Stanley and
Sheila Sidney we are so pleased that you
were able to be with us thank you thank
you so much and Roberta is the chair of
is the president of Sidney associates
that's her day job that as you'll hear
she is also a tremendous advocate for
research so thank you okay you show me
what I press okay good
yeah that's right which one
okay great okay so I'm a real estate
developer that's what I really do I'm
not I'm not a Parkinson's expert but
I've become one so I'm gonna start with
a little story so first of all anybody
in the audience with any back problems
yeah okay good so picture this you're
downsizing you're moving from a big
house in Chestnut Hill and you're moving
to a city apartment
okay picture that right so you've got to
go through closets you got to climb
through count underneath counters and
pull things out and reach here and reach
there and all of a sudden you do one
last thing and you go uh-oh and your
back goes that's it I can't move and
you're in spasm you can't do anything
you can't walk you can't sit up you
can't turn over well that was me three
weeks ago and I tell you this story
because I knew that I was going to get
better I mean obviously I'm standing
here now I I couldn't even get to the
bathroom on my own steam it was it was
pitiful but I'm I'm better what isn't so
easy is for someone who has Parkinson's
disease when they have an issue of
mobility it doesn't just get better in a
few weeks or a few days so I am gonna
speak a little bit about what it's like
to live with Parkinson's trying to speak
from the perspective of someone who has
lived with it and and give you a flavor
hopefully what that's about
so click okay so picture this here you
are young boy playing the trumpet
everything works well your hands work
your mouth works your doing doing your
thing and you're thinking about one day
maybe maybe maybe you will get the
grades and you will go to MIT that's
kind of all you're thinking about you're
not thinking about anything that's going
on in your brain you're not thinking
about dopamine you're not thinking about
popping pills you're not thinking about
anything else you're just having a
really good time so then things look
pretty good you move forward you
actually get to MIT
you get your BS your MS you're a civil
engineer you go out on your own you get
this really big sign let everybody know
what you do and you're on the jobsite
you're walking easily you're doing
everything you want to do you rock out
with your wife picture you go on safari
you're bending down you're holding a gun
you're looking you're looking really
cool and nothing nothing seems to be
wrong you're just doing doing what
you're doing you become a very young
grandfather can everybody see the
pictures I guess they're having trouble
huh okay that's the wrong way I can tell
from here that's definitely the wrong
way I don't want to touch anything how
are you doing so this is my youngest
sister on the left and my oldest niece
on the right in in dad's arms okay you
still you have no idea what's coming
ahead you know you're just blissful
having a good time and just to point out
how mobility is not a problem this is
right before the backflip I know pretty
cool right so then Parkinson's hits and
it's not so easy anymore you're still
able to stand up walk around but your
face has a mask it's a little bit
difficult smiling doesn't look quite the
same but you're out there and these are
all the grandchildren and the one on the
left in the pink that is the one that
was the little baby she's now 31 but
this was actually a few years ago
because the baby that's there is now
seven so you can do a Dolittle image but
this is a few years ago with mom and dad
standing there with with all the
grandchildren but your persevere they're
still playing the trumpet not quite so
easy anymore still playing chess but
it's it isn't quite the same thing
then you have more limitations you're in
a wheelchair you're not able to walk
anymore you're using a walker for
therapy but you're really kind of
sedentary but you're still going this is
the thing Parkinson's doesn't stop you
and you still are going this is now a
wedding so this is me and my brothers
and sisters with dad at a wedding and
Parkinson's has taken a lot of your
ability to calculate arithmetic used to
be so easy when you were at MIT you you
were so clever with math that the math
professor said I'm not going to give you
the exam your exam is to create the exam
for everyone else the only requirement
is I want you to be able to solve every
every problem you put in front of
everyone when when dad had his deep
brain stimulation surgery 10 years ago
if anyone of you knows about the surgery
you you stay awake when they actually
implant the electrodes and they're doing
different things with you and asking you
to perform certain activities open your
hands close your hands move your feet
but they also ask you questions you know
who's the president well one of the
things they ask is they ask you to count
backwards by 3 well that was too easy
for that so they said count backwards by
7 I mean I couldn't even do that now I
mean so that's that's the kind of mind
that that he has so what I would like to
say is that I feel very very fortunate
to live in a community where Boston
Medical Center exists where doctor st.
Hilaire works dad gets treatment in that
facility it's the best place to be sick
I think if you have to be sick this is
one of the best places to be sick media
the city of Boston and I also feel
extremely fortunate to be affiliated
with with MIT and the McGovern Institute
where where people are working very hard
with dr. Graybiel and everyone in her
lab to crack the code because for the
trajectory to be different for people in
this room for people who come next
we're gonna be diagnosed tomorrow we
need to know more about what causes the
disease what's going to ultimately turn
into a therapeutic difference in terms
of the lives of many people so I'm I'm
excited I'm looking forward to hearing
from our next speakers about what
they're doing and what their what
they're learning and the last picture
I'll leave you with because it's always
nice to be upbeat is still going strong
this is mom and dad having a good time
this is I think in New York a few months
ago so I just thought I'd give you a
picture sit down but not but not not out
thank you grateful Thank You Roberto and
thank you to your family for sharing
sharing their experiences with us very
moving presentation and so our next
speaker is my colleague Ann Griebel and
is a professor here at the McGovern
Institute in fact she is what is known
at MIT as an institute professor which
is the highest academic honor that MIT
confers on its faculty so we are very
whoo absolutely thrilled when Ann was
was was awarded this honor she's
received many other honors in her time
she's a member of the National Academy
of Sciences and a winner of the
presidential National Medal of Science
and is one of the most eminent
researchers in the field of Parkinson's
disease and basal ganglia and Ann is
going to talk to us about her work so
Ann
Wow
doesn't really sound much like me and
forgot to say one thing which is that I
don't know no you're good
I am so pleased that there are three
women on this panel did you even notice
that three women really thank you so
much and I'm so pleased to see your mom
and dad in the back they're wonderful
people your family is wonderful and we
are in our there's several people from
our lab here and over there and I can
tell you that every day we are inspired
by your story and by your support and by
your enthusiasm and I don't quite know
how to tell you all the way properly but
for a basic scientist to even
contemplate being able to help with this
disorder is over-the-top it's wonderful
and so we and I mean we've these
wonderful people over there and maybe
elsewhere in the back we're all working
hard so so Roberta said it I guess for
those of us who don't have Parkinson's
disease it was pretty easy in fact
probably didn't even think much about
coming in this room and finding a place
to stay food sitting down maybe being
polite and say hello to someone beside
you even if you don't know them but as
you pointed out for someone with
advanced Parkinson's disease even these
very seemingly simple behaviors become
great hurdles for example sitting down
standing up speaking clearly so so help
how could that be and I think everyone
in the room knows something about
dopamine you mentioned it that magical
neurotransmitter in the brain but bit by
bit slowly usually but inexorably
unfortunately gradually is lost in the
brain and as that loss occurs eventually
one sign and then another of Parkinson's
disease occurs and the signs may be
different some people there may be motor
problem we're familiar with that for
other people it may be more of a
psychological problem a kind of problem
with emotion for example be changing a
little bit a little bit different person
so the one thing we all can agree on is
that a terribly difficult thing for a
Parkinson's patient to do is simply to
decide to do something and do it and
this was magnificently cooked by James
Parkinson and I have his words down
below and what he said was the core
difficulty in Perkins disease is the
ability to translate your will what you
want to do into action so the normal
brain that is there a Pleader
shoot of the bodies they're great I
guess we're mit Institute of Technology
but I'm not sure we have pointers so the
dopamine interestingly shockingly we
learned is mainly in the deep middle
part of the brain the part shown here in
pink it's one on each side that's called
the striatum
you're just seeing the tip of the
iceberg it's much much bigger in another
slice and this slice actually is a very
famous brain scan one of the earliest
ones where the levodopa was radioactive
food label was very brief radioactive
label briefly there and so they could
see where this dopamine is in the normal
brain so if you now look at a comparable
image these were given me by Professor
Garnett in Canada now you see that that
dopamine that pink is almost gone this
person had severe Parkinson's disease
but to us as neurosciences this is a
spectacular mystery because we've all
thought and known and we still believe
that much of what we think and do
depends on this outer rind of the brain
the neocortex on the outside we think we
act we sing we do math with this part so
how could it be that a defect you know
like the one neurotransmitter deep in
the brain how could that so profoundly
affect a person and so that's what I'd
like to talk about and that's the
mystery we're trying to solve so there's
one part of the mystery that that that
we got a grip on the field does and
that's that curiously the deep brain
which are called the basal ganglia in
toto they have these massive highways
that eventually lead up to the front end
of the brain here is the motor cortex
famously called the premotor cortex and
here this prefrontal cortex as far
forward as you can get where we seem to
do a lot of our on online memory work a
little working memory it's called
and we plan ahead with this part and in
general we organize stuff
that's the main target outflow target of
the stratum in the basal ganglia and so
what we think in the field is going on
is that here we have this Mino cortex
shown here in this cartoon and it turns
out it itself talks down to this
dopamine rich part Australia this is the
pink part and here you can see the fiber
tract carrying dopamine up to the pink
part and you can also see in this
cartoon that basically there's a great
loop this thinking cap we have projects
fibers into the deep brain that deeper
end gets modulated by the dopamine
coming up here that dopamine is carrying
fascinating signals there's sort of
predictive signals that help us to
choose what to do next and so all of
these loops that are going around seem
to have something to do seem very much
they have to do with selecting and being
able to do the next thing and the next
thing until you get a whole sequential
behavior and once you do that behavior a
few times you get what we would call a
routine know if the dopamine you can see
in this diagram gradually goes away and
it actually goes away because these
tracks that I'm showing you here in this
cartoon that tracked dyes back and as it
dies back not enough dopamine gets here
and then this region is disordered in
the selection the ability for example to
say I want now to pick up this Bible
that becomes impossible because because
of the disorder deep down it's so that's
part of this amazing and to us very
surprising mystery
the deep part of the brain should
influence what we do through its effects
on the big king of the brain the
neocortex so that's good this is all
good so in fact there are a lot of
things now in the Parkinson's field that
are definitely good hopeful promising
for example we roughly know the circuits
I just showed you one cartoon and we're
more and more beginning to learn about
some positive or predisposing genes used
to be thought Parkinson's wasn't genetic
now it looks like some forms may be many
forms behind them lies some darn
mutation somewhere in some genes we know
that often the dopamine loss is
relatively slow the dying back is slow
in that tract and what that means is
that's good because there's lots of time
for therapies to be developed and even
if you're dealing with right now there
is a period when therapies can help
leading among all of the therapies being
as I think you all know the levodopa
therapies such as cinnamon that that
that is given to patients now and I have
just put this deep brain stimulation
that you mentioned that your dad had
that surgery and maybe in the discussion
period where I would love to talk about
that I'm probably going to run out of
time but I'm happy to talk about it
what I do want to talk about is that
despite all those good things we've got
some pretty major challenges in in the
research side of things and the first
thing and it's almost hard to believe so
I have to ask you to believe me we still
do not know what dopamine does to those
circuits it's crazy we have known about
the dopamine loss for years and years
and years since the 1960s a bit by bit
people have learned many exquisite
things about the action of this little
molecule in the
but if you ask something simple like you
know if I can't pick up the water bottle
what is it about no dopamine that makes
me unable to do that we can't give a
very clear and crispy answer we need
that answer because if we can figure out
what the dopamine does even if we can't
prevent it from going away we might be
able to zoom in there with a new method
and mimic what it does do there is
another thing which I'd like to talk
about just at the end of the talk and
several people here to Crittenden among
them has worked together with us in the
lab very hard on this problem which is
as some of you know for someone who is
given the levodopa therapy after a
certain number of years there may be
complications so paradoxically and sadly
now the person who's sort of frozen
locked in suddenly starts making
movements that he doesn't the person
doesn't intend to do famously in the
case of welcome Terry Fox who's done a
great service by showing people the
circle of levodopa dyskinesias we've
gotta get rid of those because right now
levodopa and allied so-called agonist
therapies are therapies of choice so we
decided we let's start simple we are
simple let's just talk about the problem
that a Parkinson's patient has getting
going like starting to walk and stopping
this is something that we all know but
eventually becomes a real problem well
we want to know why this is so tough for
the Parkinson's patient we know that the
levodopa which replaces the dopamine
that's gradually going away we know it
helps we understand apply and again I
say
in our lab we're in other labs - we have
the belief that this very fundamental
research if we could figure it out might
be able to help people so don't laugh
I'm going to tell you about mice it bees
mice we we want to see how they do start
and stop in a task such as walking down
a corridor and making a decision to turn
to the left or turn to the right and
there's a little door in the corridor
that's a little door in this simple
psychology t-maze and we can pull that
door away the animal initiates a
movement he runs down in our case we
play little musical notes to tell him to
go right or left to get to the end of
the corridor and our mice love chocolate
and we give them chocolate at the end of
the corridor and so you can actually see
this I have a couple of videos those
sound you hear is the sound of neurons
you'll hear them again
little tiny quick electrical bits of
information that rose announced dr. Yin
you got it I'm going to show you three
runs there he goes let's try the other
side was baby he can't see the baby
now watch on the third one if you seen
him try to figure out which way to go
but I like to think that he's in my team
now so he did figure it out you know
what what did we do well you may have
noticed that this mouse is carrying us
funny-looking hat and this hat actually
carries a lot of very very very fine
wires maybe twelve microns in diameter
down deep into that pink zone of the
mouse into the striatum and so all we've
decided to do is to say okay let's take
the naive mouse or rat let's have you
learned to do this behavior let's see
what happens to the neurons in there
it's something that had not been known
and I'm going to show you a call
plot to show you what happens and the
first thing to say is here's the maze
and the maze time the run times they'd
go this way so here's the waiting queue
the gate opens he starts here are those
tones that tell him to go right or left
he turns it's done with a turn and gets
to go so that's time and we're gonna
follow the activity as he learns and
learning is going to go down this way
and the bright red shows you high
activity of those nerve cells in
Australia and so what you can see looks
rather I guess dull in that as he's
running down there are tons of neurons
that fire a lot a lot of her baseline
and they're firing away and it looks er
like they just fired a lot that's it and
this grass stops when he learns that's
the sort of psychology criterion for
learning but uh look what happens when
he really learns that pants we were
stunned by this and this is now we've
seen this a number of times and
different species actually that that
activity that was all over begins to
pile up yes we're at the beginning in
the end of the runs so we're looking at
each other we're saying wait a minute so
we actually have spent some years
looking at this no it's not philosophy
it's not acceleration or deceleration
and number of different things they seem
to be some kind of communication or
computational signals some kind of brain
talk so of course we got very excited
about this because you saw that these
signals weren't there when the mouse
didn't know how to do the task
these were alert these were learned
acquired signals the brain learned these
signals and curiously enough when we
learn to do something like come as a
routine to a room like this I reckon we
probably have them too
and then maybe we just package that
behavior and say you know this is good
behavior to have why don't I put little
brain markers little signals around it
that's our idea that somehow action
boundary representations form and we've
done a lot of work on this we know that
time is embedded in these
representations but I I won't show you
all of that what I will say is it of
course it came to mind to say you don't
suppose this has anything to do with
Parkinson's disease and I cannot truly
say that we know but there is work
that's been done by some people in the
room and also a very wonderful postdoc
Vidya Hernandez who just went back to
Spain but about a week ago and I've got
to tell you what we've been doing to try
to find out whether there was crazy
beginning and end signals have anything
to do with Parkinson's disease and the
way Lydia and the group decided to work
on this is to shown here this is a
little cross section through the mouse
brain or rat brain and the pink region
is here that's a stratum and this little
dark part shows where we made
experimentally a lesion of the dopamine
system such that we mimic the dying back
of the dopamine fibers that occurs in
Parkinson's disease
that is to say in this little region
here the dopamine is just about gone and
we now have very fancy ways to measure
that in these brains so here's the
really great set up this is a hinny
parkinsonian model one-sided
parkinsonian model the animal is
perfectly fine to go continue to do or
to learn to do the maze tasks because we
only took out dopamine in one little
part of the sensory motor part and we
put electrodes these that I showed you
before I mean a little mouse we put them
here inside their place where dopamine
was gone and then we put them in
the same place on the other side where
everything was normal and I want to show
you the the shocking result and actually
some of these results are I don't know
whether in the room but some of these
results have been so recently analyzed
that we're still in a state of shock but
but let me show you now what I'm showing
you is what neurons look like on the
control side this is the good side
we didn't take away the dopamine sure
enough another set of animals in fact
they've got this kind of thing going on
their heads they form the beginning and
end pattern that's fun
now I'm going to click on what goes on
in the depleted side for some of the
neurons there it is they can't do it
this is one subset of the neurons right
there in the pink zone so to say they
can't do beginning in those are feeling
neurons in in there there are other
neurons and we do what's called
classification divide them up into
groups best we can and so we have
another group and now I'm showing you
dopamine deplete it the bad side of the
brain these guys on their bad side they
can form a beautiful pattern even though
the dopamine is very very low it's just
the hint of dopamine left as Marc house
sitting over there approved but look
what happens when we give them levodopa
what happens is this stuff goes away and
they get a most magnificent big signal
right at the time the gate has been open
the guys gotta go they fire and look at
how strong the firing is here compared
to before the therapy when they get to
the end that's interesting so this is a
good experiment you could kick the
dopamine away and you do it in an
experiment and hey that's not
Parkinson's what about a
model of Parkinson's and by that I mean
how about have a many as I said genes
now being discovered that can predispose
people to to having Parkinson's disease
suppose we had a mouse who has one of
those genes in him so he's a kind of
parkinsonian model Mel's what's going on
with the cells there and here's the work
of Eric do dinner please bow right over
there but they don't put the laser light
in his eyes and eric has done a hero's
effort of looking at the very first and
still extremely famous Parkinson's
mutation circle alpha-synuclein and here
is the control side with a lot of
activity at start in this subset of
cells and doggone it
the office' nuclear mutant this just
doesn't have enough so what I'm telling
you is that even starting with something
so straightforward is just what is it
that Parkinson's people really have
trouble doing if we go into the brain
and try to record the activity signals
that might be related to that behavior
we can find that those signals are very
very elegant
they're very beautifully organized they
develop as we learn and they definitely
are badly affected in at least two
models of Parkinson's disease in which
the amount of dopamine in the pink zone
the stratum has gone way down can we fix
this isn't this an onion now the next
slide we fixed it right well of course
we haven't but we're we're we're trying
so what we have to get at we have to get
at the dopamine containing neurons
themselves and this sounds easy but it's
not so oh they can't see this you gotta
see this we have to turn the light down
if it's just too pretty
so we should have this thing on
this is an IQ test obviously yeah oh
yeah but it needs to go further oh you
know it's because it filming oh you see
oh well just for a second this per
second because gosh never mind anyway
there's some red cells there and those
cells this is what we're after these are
dopamine containing neurons and we know
because they're red we've it's just Oh
isn't it pretty
was it worth it so nowadays very very
recently partly developed here at Mi BR
and partly at Stanford you can engineer
listen to this a virus to carry the
molecule of your choice into the brain
in MJ Kim who's name is here has done
that in this animal and these green
cells here they have a very special
virus that that's in them and in this
which again I'm afraid is hard for you
to see with all these lights these
yellowy things these are the cells that
are bona fide E we can turn the lights
back on
those are do turn the lights on
those are dopamine containing neurons
that now have been infected by a virus
that has been engineered so it will only
affect dopamine containing neurons yeah
thanks to the wonders of very very
recent of science including work by Carl
dyes are off and two people here
fittings on and ed Boyden we can now
make that hat that the mice wear also
have a light guide and here you see this
blue light and this thing sits on is
really here and so we can put this
little light fabric down right to where
the virus-infected the dopamine cells
and if we turn that light on we can make
the dopamine cells turn on and get
active or we can turn them off and I
thank you Janet that Ken's for helping
us with this this is a very very
exciting experiment hasn't been done
before to our knowledge and we're going
to have animals who are doing a task who
will then have us manipulate whether the
dopamine is on or off and we're
extremely much hoping that that will
give us a whole new view of what might
be going on it's crazy that this isn't
known it just isn't now another reason
why it isn't known is that we haven't
had a good way to stick a probe down
into the Pink's on the striatum and
actually measure how much dopamine is
there we can do it with a very crude
method but the the timescale of the
method is many minutes like you
something happens in the brain and you
don't get your readout until 20 or 30
minutes later now there is a way to do
this and this is an engineered job by
mark Howell he's also sitting over there
about to be electrocuted by the laser
and we can put in this same headset that
the little animals carry by the way
that's only weighs two point two grams
it's pretty light we can put down a
fiber like this and Mark is able in the
animal who's running around to measure
in real time how much dopamine is being
spewed out of those fibers that were
coming up that tracked into the pink
zone the one securing the dopamine and
when Mark does that oh look at this all
night he's now our sooner color signals
showing you the dopamine concentration
and actually this black line shows where
the warning she was in the maze and the
animal starts and found there's a big
skirt up there for me that's a good fact
to know so everywhere we're turning now
we're seeing that probably part of the
problem with that that you guys know in
the back of the room and some others
here the trouble with getting yourself
going or once you go stopping yourself
from going partly may lie in disordering
of these signals and the signals are
getting finger and we need to find out
about them we need to know exactly what
the signals are when they occur what
influences them and how to restore them
even if we can't restore yet the
dopamine itself so that is a very
important I talked a long time I want to
close by coming back to the levodopa
therapy and the terrible thing that
we've needed up a therapy maybe I don't
underst is Keynesians can occur that
means abnormal movements occur and so
job Crittenden whose name is here Jill
and small team and I disagree had
actually discovered some genes we found
these genes are probably important for
this generation of these bad movements
and there is one gene array result the
more dyskinesia you have these are
dyskinesia scores and animals have
animal of dyskinesias the more here this
red gene is being expressed this is a
gene the more that you've got for more
discipline issues you've got and so Jill
I started a wonderful experiment it's
done going she did a mouse marriage we
had mass marriage in the lab we all
intended
and and the mouse that was married to
mice that were married were mice that
another PD model Mouse it's got a crazy
name they got married through our mouse
which Jill had created and this mouse
lacks because she engineered it out this
lacks the gene that get more of this
James when you've got more discipline
Asia's so we're hoping that if that Jane
has something to do with causing more
dyskinesias if we make a knock out of
that gene that mouse to a guy who's got
Parkinson's disease maybe we'll have
less dyskinesias so babies are born and
we're gonna find out when they grow up
if they are grown up some of them do
they have fewer these Keynesians when we
give them to levodopa therapy so the
last videos this is a one of those PD
model my C city in a lab beaker but you
know nothing very interesting but this
is interesting now I'm going to show you
two months this mouse it's like a news
this this mouse over here I'm going to
start the video in a minute he's the PD
model Mouse he's been giving me the dope
of therapy this mouse over here here
he's a the attempt at rescuing reducing
the levodopa therapies our Mouse's been
crossed up to the PD Mouse and bees are
this guy's an offspring sir if you give
levodopa to the PD model Mouse he gets
cowardice punishes you can see him
jumping around it's really frightful to
see this this is Mouse levodopa induced
dyskinesias and they don't have to be in
a jar to do it and here is the same
mouse only now he lacks the gene we
discovered and that jill has worked so
hard on
and you can see how much less this guy
is moving around compared so in summary
we think now that there's some potential
for doing Turnitin gene therapy to help
with this problem and of course the way
they'd like to do the therapy is to have
some drug that could be given an
association with therapeutic drugs we
have to make those levodopa dyskinesias
go away we are so grateful to you and to
the Parkinson's organizations and I just
I know I talked a long time but I'd like
to say that I personally am deeply
grateful to people who have worked on
this I've mentioned several of these
names to you today these are people who
are really wonderful and really
dedicated and we're all hoping we can
help thank you
good Thank You Anne well I've learnt
something new today the metaphor of
marriage for studying Mouse genetics and
it's indeed a wonderful marriage of
basic research and its clinical
application so thank you again our final
speaker of the evening is dr. Marie st.
Hilaire dr. Sinclair is a she received
her indeed from the University of
Montreal and she is now a faculty member
at Boston University Medical Center
where she is an associate professor from
urology she also directs the Center for
Disease and movement disorders research
and movement disorders there I was just
studying her memory resume trying to
commit it to memory and she is also the
center the director of center for
research excellence that is supported by
the American Parkinson disease
Association and she is also a member of
the scientific advisory board and just
looking at her resume I have it here if
anyone would like to research i'm very
impressed at the extraordinary range of
of your research interests and
activities everything from studying new
testing the efficacy of new therapies to
basic basic studies on the genetics of
parkinson's disease so and we're honored
to have you with us tonight and looking
forward to your presentation thank you
thank you so much for inviting me this
is a great honor here to be talking here
so I'm going to just give an update of
the clinical research in Parkinson what
are the important directions that the
clinicians and mainly clinicians what we
think would be important areas for the
treatment the clinical treatment of
people who have Parkinson's disease
okay let's advance alright so the
important areas of research I'm going to
talk about today are the preclinical
diagnosis the trying to find biomarkers
neuroprotection
which is an important field of research
and clinical research in Parkinson's
disease and we'll talk a little bit
about new symptomatic treatment the I
just want to show you the difference how
the shift had there's been a shift in
how we treat Parkinson's disease so
initially or what we do now is that we
do we make the diagnosis of Parkinson
disease based on clinic somebody
presents with the classical symptoms of
Parkinson's - tremor the rigidity the
slowness and really it's a neurologist
who has experience with Parkinson's
disease it makes the diagnosis we at
this point have no blood tests it's not
an MRI or a PET scan that will help us
to make the diagnosis so by that time
people say about 70% of the dopamine
cells have already died in the brain and
the way we treat people is by giving
them l-dopa or cinnamon it's by
replacing dopamine's when the other
medications dopamine agonist and mao-b
inhibitors and CMT inhibitors but the
goal of all these medication is
basically to increase the level of
dopamine in the brain but there are two
caveats one dr. Graybiel talked about it
is that the medication causes abnormal
momentary movements called dyskinesia
and the other one is as the disease
progress patients have symptoms that do
not respond to dopamine so it appears
that their dopamine is that the onions
are there only there are other
neurotransmitters that may be involved
and we don't replace them well at this
point so there are certain symptoms such
as depression autonomic dysfunction
which includes low blood pressure severe
constipation urinary problems
some people develop cognitive problems
and all these problems do not respond
well to the levodopa so now what we want
to do is that's the new target what
we're trying to do in Clicquot research
in Parkinson is doing early diagnosis
and try to treat the cause or find a
treatment that will either slow down the
disease ideally would stop the disease
progression so we know that Parkinson
disease may start years before the motor
symptoms appear and there are certain
things certain signs or symptoms that
seem to be more associated to this
prodromal phase which could be sometimes
even 15 years before the motor symptoms
start the one that is best known as a
factory loss losing the sense of smell
and some patients will tell us that
they've lost her sense of smell years
and years and years ago another symptom
is something called REM behavior
disorder so the person is not paralyzed
normally like we should be during the
dream when we dream we usually paralyze
and our muscles don't move but people
have that disorder will not be paralyzed
during their dream their brain is very
active during the dream so people scream
and trash sometimes fall out of bed
during when they dream other things are
auto nammed disorders especially
constipation and some people might have
depression or anxiety years before
they're diagnosed with their Parkinson
disease so what we think is that there's
this pointer prodromal phase and there's
this time of you know a few years where
people do not have the tremor or the
rigidity of Parkinson's disease but have
all these other symptoms and then
eventually when the loss of dopamine
gets worse or rate it reaches an area of
the brain controlling movement
then they start to develop the motor
symptoms of Parkinson's so what we're
trying to do is try to find out who's
there and if we have a good treatment
eventually that is neuroprotective give
the treatment there that's our goal
so there's this big study that is taking
place now funded by the Department of
Defense called the pars study it's to
find out if we can identify risk factors
or identify people or have the risk part
factor who may be at risk for developing
Parkinson's disease so it was a
multicenter study we were a Center at BU
but for of course we had like 15,000
individuals so there were many centers
doing it so there were people who had
Parkinson disease relatives or people
who were not really relatives of parts
and disease but all these people did not
have the disease okay they were just
volunteer and to screen all these people
it was great to the mail we sent them a
special smell test with a scratch and
sniff and they returned the test as
subsets of these people came in to be
evaluated clinically and they got
imaging and then about 450 P of these
subjects will be followed for five years
with the imaging and the smell tests and
cognitive tests and clinical tests so we
will try to see if we can detect in
advance so predict in advance who is at
risk of developing Parkinson's so so far
what we found is you'll see the color
under less so people had the very very
lower sense of smell so they were in
below the 11th percentile of normal for
their sense of smell so they a decrease
sense of smell has a much higher risk of
having loved symptoms I talked about the
constipation the depression the anxiety
the read behavior disorder of course was
elevated
so we if we think one is normal is like
so anything above one is a higher risk
so for REM behavior disorder it was two
point four five four seven and it if you
have it was even higher risk if you had
two or more of these symptoms so there
seems to be a constellation of symptoms
that if we follow people we might be
able to see who would be at the risk of
developing Parkinson's so that's one
area of study the other one that's very
important is trying to find a biomarker
I said mentioned in the beginning the
diagnosis of Parkinson is made on a
clinical basis by an experienced
physician the it's only when the motor
symptoms have appeared that we can make
the diagnosis okay but we don't have any
blood tests it's not an MRI it's not a
PET scan study even genetic testing that
tells us who has Parkinson's disease so
a biomarker is really a sign that we you
know helps you diagnose a disease for
example if you have sugar and your urine
probably have diabetes okay
so there these are the potential
biomarkers and having study I mentioned
the smell test
constipation this is a PET scan genetic
testing some people have looked at
cardiac innovation and at the
transcranial ultrasound of the
substantia [ __ ] so the Michael J Fox
foundation has put a lot of money trying
to find a biomarker and has funded a
study called the ppm I study basically
it is six hundred subjects overall so
four hundred will have have Parkinson
and two hundred or controls and they
have they follow very strict protocol
all these subjects who have Parkinson's
disease are very early on in their
disease they're not taking any
occasion yet because they want to be
they want them to be studied before the
effect of the medication could interfere
with the result of the testing these
they have go through a very standardized
protocol of evaluation so this includes
men to do that scans this form of scan
nuclear scan MRI motor assessment no
psychiatry cognitive testing they go
through several spinal taps check your
urine stored their DNA so and eventually
trying to find if we can find anything
in all this information that we are
gathering that wouldn't help us the test
for developing Parkinson's for the
diagnosing Parkinson disease this is
just to show you a that scan or be a
better CIT scan which measures as
automobile method mentioned the amount
of dopamine and the brain and you see on
the right it's brighter than on the left
so we know Parkinson disease also
I'll always starts asymmetrically so
it's always worse on one side of the
brain and the other so the left side
which controls the right side of your
body is you know you have decrease in
dopamine so your Parkinson's worse on
your right side and you see as the
disease progress the amount of dopamine
decreases in the brain so this is a test
that is used at the moment for research
we use it also sometimes to confirm
parkinsonism but it's not a test that is
useful to differentiate the various
forms of parkinsonism yo Pathak
Parkinson's disease versus other forms
such as multi system atrophy of
progressive supranuclear palsy but it
does help us confirm that at least the
people coming to the study do have a
form of parkinsonism so just do a little
summary you see that the pars we're
trying to find people before
or they show the motor science of
Parkinson's disease and the PPM I study
it's when people have already been
diagnosed with Parkinson's disease
trying to find a biomarker and the goal
is really because if we can diagnose it
really early or pre clinically is to
start a neuro protective treatment this
is the holy grail of Neurology and
treating Parkinson disease we really
want to stop the disease find a
treatment very early on and then prevent
the progression of the disease and
prevent these complications and even the
motor complications so this is you don't
have to read all this but this is just a
list of all the medications and
treatments that have been tried so far
as near a protective treatment in
Parkinson so we haven't found anything
very promising yet but these are all
clinical studies we these all studies
were done in the patients who
volunteered their time for for science
people I've heard about Co Q 10 this has
been proven now that it's not effective
there are two other studies that are
going on at the moment and there are
several others when it's creatine one is
I know seen them talked about I know
Singh cos it's done across the river
here and at Boston University also where
we give a substance it's a supplement in
fact not even American it's a supplement
that increased the level of uric acid in
the blood and in big epidemiological
studies it has been shown that people
who have a higher level of uric acid
have a slower rate of progression so the
goal is trying to elevate the uric acid
but keep it within a normal range
because we don't want to cause gout so
but the patients are wonderful they
monitor their urine pH the way to do it
is monitoring urine pH to present to
prevent kidney stones and they have
visits every two weeks and we measured
their levels
and the other medications call Israeli
pain it's an old blood pressure
medication a calcium channel blocker
which has been on the market for many
years it's not used very much but there
are studies showing that the that it
could be neuroprotective and Parkinson's
so that study is also going on in
patients I want to mention something
about exercise because there's a lot of
data in animals and I've presenting one
study there are many studies and mouse
and model and even in monkey models
showing that exercise physical exercise
could have a role in neural protection
it's unfortunately very difficult to
believe in humans but if you create a
mouse model with giving them a compound
called
mptp and then you exercise those mice
you find that the mice to receive mptp
compared to the mice who receive mptp
and did not exercise have less
impairment in their movements than the
mice who did not exercise and this was
associated with some improved brain
function and some neurotrophic factors
secretion in the brain so it's very
difficult to prove in humans you cannot
tell a group of people who have
Parkinson disease okay you exercise
three times a week and you tell another
group now don't do anything it says and
it did these studies in their protection
for Parkinson have to be done over three
to five years it's very long range
because the loss of dopamine the
progression is slow so these are very
expensive you require hundreds of people
per group so I mean people are trying to
design a study to do that but it has
been challenging we know at least for
epidemiological study and there are
several epidemiological studies this is
also one of them showing that they
these were this were a big cohort of a
hundred forty three thousand people who
were followed in a cancer prevention
study and what they found was the people
who had the highest category of
recreational activity so people who
exercise the most has a lower risk of
developing Parkinson's disease
so either Parkinson disease reduces your
yeah exercise reduces your risk of
Parkinson disease or maybe if you have
preclinical Parkinson disease maybe you
don't exercise as much but this is why
we always tell our patients who have
been newly diagnosed with Parkinson's
very important to do exercise very early
to put them on exercise program as soon
as you're diagnosed I'll talk I'll
finish with the symptomatic treatment
there are a lot of treatments that have
been developed at the moment I'll just
mention some a few and in passing there
are some new levodopa formulations
something called dual dopa which is a
gel that brings the level of but
directly into the stomach through a
g-tube the problem with cinnamon the
regular cinnamon is that the half-life
is very short it's 90 minutes so when a
person has advanced Parkinson's disease
gay men might have to take their
medication every 90 minutes to two hours
because the duration of action is very
short and advanced Parkinson so the dude
oppa is a way to give the the dopinder
l-dopa the precursor to dopamine on a
more even continuous basis
unfortunately l-dopa is not very soluble
so you cannot really put in a patch it's
very difficult to put in a patch and it
cannot be given subcutaneously other
medications that are being studied that
dr. Graybiel talked about the problems
with dyskinesia some anti dyskinetic
medications are being studied at the
moment
presently the only thing to do if you
have very severe dyskinesia there one
medication call amantadine which might
help a little bit otherwise it's going
to deep rain simulation so there are
studies being done on rehabilitation
exercise new agentive medications to
help the aldo power cinnamon work better
some say some magnetic stimulation and
some surgical therapies the deep brain
stimulation is really not a research
surgery because really it's really
approved by the FDA and they love people
are going through the other surgery when
they have advanced Parkinson's but the
ones that are being studied at the
moment one is nurturing and that was
then give seem to be giving any great
result it's introducing a neuro trophic
factors directly into the brain one is
introducing a genes as produce glutamic
acid decarboxylase so basically they
attach the gene to an inactivated virus
and put it in the area of the brain
called the subthalamic nucleus and
basically that gene does what the deep
brain stimulation does it's just a
chemical the brain simulation and the
pro 7 is a combination of genes that
wouldn't be also introduced in the brain
and it helped to increase the level of
dopamine in the brain so these are all
right you know presented as gene therapy
but they don't really correct the
abnormal gene that's causing Parkinson
it's basically a genetic way to either
increase the level of dopamine in the
brain or to enhance it young
the neuro trophic factors in the brain
there's at the moment very little brain
stem cell research being done clinically
in patients with Parkinson people I know
people always interested about stem
cells at the moment stem cells is still
mostly studied in animals there's one
city of autologous bone marrow derived
stem cells where they took the owns the
patient's own stem cells and in play
them and the basal ganglia of somebody
who had Parkinson's disease and they've
got very good results but that was on
very few patients and there was no
control group and we always like to have
a control group the one that seems to be
promising is that glutamic acid
decarboxylase therapy so it is basically
it's reducing a gene in the subthalamic
nucleus that sort of decreases the
activity of that nucleus and we and this
does the same thing as deep brain
stimulation does but without having all
the hardware that people have when they
have the brain stimulation which
includes having an electrode in the
brain a wire that goes under the skin
and a battery under the skin and the
battery has to be in how can I say
change from time to time so there's a
lot of hardware it can be infected it
can break this is basically doing the
same thing as these the brain
stimulation but just by putting in a
gene that would do the same thing
decrease the activity of that nucleus
and that seems very promising and there
will be other studies about that I'd
like to suggest that the speakers will
come up and sit at the front we have
questions for hours because yes sir
positions from Montreal I understand the
french-canadian gene pool is rather
limited as only several thousand people
settled up there initially and several
as I used 70,000 roughly when the
British took over is that area been of a
hotbed of the genetic problems yes in
Quebec there are certain conditions that
have been described there for example at
sexy the shallow West acne and there is
the the incidence of tay-sachs disease
in certain areas of Quebec is even
higher than in the Ashkenazi Jewish
population so there are there are
several diseases that are more frequent
in that area I know my gene pool keeps
running across relatives in it they kept
marrying their cousins good other
questions yes yeah I think there's late
their arms the question is looking for
behavior markers but what what they're
doing is really its movement its mortar
whether it's well by that time it means
that it's - is the disease has advanced
to the point where you see the motor
aspect where once seen before the motor
aspect and there are people who are
doing a lot of research I didn't talk
about cognition in Parkinson's disease
there's a lot of you know research being
done maybe some of it even here with
functional MRIs PET scans and question
is if I understood him correctly last
night I believe
Isaacson was doing some research at
MacLean using bluer potent stem cells
through the Janish lab and seemed to
have extremely good results now it's
only five or six patients but they were
getting good results over what six years
did I understand that correctly patients
on people I'm not patient yes
that's a the does gender appear to play
a role in either the incidents of
Parkinson's or its or in its progression
yes
Parkinson is more frequent in men than
in women so we any we don't know why
it's not very well understood they look
at estrogens and hormones but it's not
very well understood
maybe I'll not have another know more
about that but and as far as progression
is concerned we know that women tend to
have more dyskinesias than men
clinically we know also that men appear
to have more cognitive problems than
women
just bears it's another profession there
are a lot of studies now on that very
issue there are some signs that
yes can you comment on whether there's
any familial connections and if there
are do you do you start looking at
family members early on there it's a
very good question
Lia sure about this it appears that if
you have a member of your fellow us
Parkinson's disease you might be at
slightly increased risk of having
Parkinson's there are certain genes that
have been described that cause
Parkinson's some some of them are very
clear that they cause Parkinson
they're like autosomal dominant if one
of your parents have it you have a 50/50
chance of getting it the Parkinson's
very very rare it's that sign you clean
gene extremely rare not only a few
families they are certain a certain gene
called lark - which is probably more
frequent that is affecting mostly people
around the Mediterranean and it's kind
easy
Jews that really increases very much a
risk of having Parkinson's disease but
it doesn't mean that you're going to
have Parkinson's disease which means
that your risk is much very increased
but we do we have a very big genetic
study of families who have Parkinson
disease at BU and most of the people in
that study so these all people have more
than two members family of Parkinson
disease most of these people do not have
any of the genes that have been so far
discovered or described so there are
many genes that have not been found or
maybe that's not one gene it's a
combination of gene that will cause the
increased risk of Parkinson so at this
point we don't use genetic testing
unless there's a very specific question
to make the diagnosis
yeah there there's a there's a there may
be some things in the environment which
could at least increase your risk of
Parkinson's disease and some people
think that maybe if you have a gene
predisposing you with the right
environment that could cause a Parkinson
this was it was proposed by dr. bow-bow
bow-bow in fact in Quebec showing that
there was an increased risk of
developing Parkinson
if you live in certain rural areas which
means to invest aside or near paper
mills that has led to another area of
research of environmental factors I
caused Parkinson's for example rotenone
that is a pesticide is used to the fore
as a model of partisan business in
animals so maybe it's a another gene by
itself or a combination of a gene and
the right environment that could cause a
wrong environment a good constant
partners I think we may be just a couple
more questions because we do have a
reception outside and so we can continue
the conversation informally but I think
two people have had their hand up I
wondered if there's been any study much
work done on interactions of the work
you've done with behavioral or emotional
factors in individuals the effect the
increased number of placebo in impact
for example or you talked about
chocolate being the motivator maybe if
you used ice cream it would create a
different impact of just being facetious
but
oh refer to our physician panelists but
I will say that it's stunning what
recibo is so-called placebo effect does
the scans that you showed and I did two
PET scans of dopamine dopamine can be
increased enormously by such things as
chocolate and by the very thought that
maybe you'd get better if you take a you
know a certain therapy so this is this
is good and it speaks to something I
think we would all agree that to to
quite a a level this is a situational
kind of effect in other words in many of
these disorders that affect the stratum
and the basal ganglia the symptoms can
be worse in some situations for example
anxiety can bring out problems it's
again I turn to Michael J Fox who has
these terrible dyskinesias and he makes
a very strong point about it for example
in his interview with Katie Couric they
G you know when he's under pressure for
example in such an interview on a with a
television cameras Darren right at him
that his dyskinesias are ever so much
worse than otherwise and you just have
to think and we now in science do think
that state circuits now jargon is to
call that state that some some state of
mind some some modulators in the brain
to influence but otherwise we you would
think it's a more steady situation it's
a wonderful question
so I know we had one more question sir
if you want to ask your question before
we wrap up you okay so here we can send
everybody's questions that's wonderful
so and good thank you and thank you
again to all those people